alors premier terrain visé ce soir aussi
inséparables que jobijoba wallis et
futuna hôpitaux et marion les bonnie and
clyde du paf eric zemmour est écrit
voilà et nous on se rappelle qu'à
l'unité rien le goût est vraiment
fortune et le hashtag tasse de thé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs
voici mon cdd il est toujours ont cédé
les tomes villa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sabathia et où l'on doit bien tout va
très bien tu me dit laurent si tu as
besoin de moi j'ai eu un petit coup pas
tout de suite tu vois ça nous oblige à
les cacher will i am et après ces deux
mots le pauvre laurent c'est bon super
merci on a un plateau extraordinaire et
je fais je vais remarquer en préparant
les missions que à par capucine tout le
monde un surnom voir il ya l'homme en
noir si le gros porc mais
oui aussi maintenant l'homme en noir le
sniper chinois marrant le flingueur
eric zemmour
tient nos invités suivants font partie
d'un duo célèbre comme peter et sloane
voilà ils ont tenté une carrière solo
comme peter et sloane et finalement
c'est ado qu'on les préfère comme peter
et sloane c'est eric zemmour et eric
naulleau
5 on est on est heureux de les retrouver
en duo c'est un peu comme ntm vous nous
aviez manqué les gars là on a découvert
vous à découvrir dans on n'est pas
couché voilà où vous aviez le type de
flingueur eric naulleau voilà flingueurs
du paf d'ailleurs à l'époque francis
lalanne vous avez menacé dans les
coulisses voilà il vous est proposé de
chanter une chanson a cappella afin -
sais pas ce qui s'est passé
et
aiguisé moss est le seul à avoir fait la
gueule après avoir appris que paris
allait organiser les jo en 2024 à cause
du nombre de sportifs étrangers qu'on va
recevoir comme ça non non non non du jeu
non mais je rigole évidemment parce que
je vous cache pas que j'aime bien les
arabes et j'aime bien les femmes donc dû
bouge pas un très grand fan d'eric
zemmour mais après c'est eric naulleau
donc vous faites votre rentrée
sur paris première dans l'émission
politique zemmour et naulleau voilà une
rentrée le 11 octobre mais mal afin
qu'ils apprennent pas aussi tard
franchement vous déconnez zemmour et
naulleau c'est une émission qui
arbitrait par anaïs bouton qui paraît-il
pour tenir les missions après des cours
avec les négociateurs du raid
[Applaudissements]
et d'ailleurs eric naulleau vous aviez
dit dans une interview à propos de la
télé réalité je ne sais pas si on peut
descendre plus bas vous l'aviez dit oui
c'est pourquoi il y aura un grand débat
se soit entre capucines à eric zemmour
pour savoir si on a besoin d'avoir fait
beaucoup d'études pour raconter beaucoup
de caunes routière et bonne émission
merci
on retrouve maman
en l'état
est ce le prélude walter
et maintenant mesdames messieurs on
passe à nos invités polémique de la
semaine
[Musique]
c'est génial de vous avoir tous les deux
en face de moi j'ai l'impression d'être
laurent ruquier
eric zemmour avec nous leurs bons soirs
alors à partir du 11 octobre tous les
mercredis à 20h50 sur paris première
c'est le retour de votre émission
zemmour et naulleau animé et arbitré par
la fameuse anaïs bouton alba ventura
fait partie aussi de l'aventuré puisque
elle décrypte les coulisses de la vie
politique de régulation défi non alors
on arrête toi maintenant arrête toi
lance l on met des juges est la tête
basse la terre est ce que vous savez
pourquoi la chaîne est toujours cryptée
c'est pas à cause de zemmour
c'est le csa qui a estimé que nous
n'étions pas digne de passer en clair
pourquoi vous savez pourquoi alors
qu'ils ont expliqué pourquoi non que
paris première n'était pas une chaîne
assez original et moi ma théorie
personnelle c'était plutôt une décision
politique c'est pourtant le csa est un
organisme indépendant de toute politique
là j'allais le dire jamais le dire mais
vous m'avez précédé diables ont salué le
cs oui ah ça c'est bien ça c'est bien
à cette saison j'étais quoi le meilleur
moment eric zemmour je pense qu'il ya eu
des mois ce que j'ai aimé il ya eu des
débats assez assez musclé oui il y avait
mon frère est venu avec un pilote est
fort non il ya deux types de deux types
de débats musclés il ya des débats
intellectuellement exigent donc il faut
nous savez pour nous c'est formidable on
s'accroche et tous on se bat avec des
jambons et puis il ya des débats où il
faut s'accrocher à la table et est
rentré dedans comme avec tapis comme
avec dupont moretti comme avec d'autres
mais c'est 2 2 il faut ces deux
registres différents il ya des débats
cérébraux et des débats hormonaux pas
tout à fait la même ambiance meehan
j'argumente est ce que les gens viennent
pour s'affronter à vous on est dedans je
vais me payer zemmour j'ai tout le temps
ça ouais alors il y en a qui rendent
directement j'ai pas dit encore un mot
ouais non mais je vous assure que c'est
parfois c'est un peu surprenant et il
m'a grèce antique vous allez dire oui
oui sans doute mais celle il a changé
tellement m justement cherché un jour il
m'a dit laurent baffie vous ne m'avez
jamais fait rire il a il est l heure
était mort de rire depuis que je ne
respecte plus les familles les
dépouiller de
ses fous alors est ce que mr viana les
chinois toujours un titulaire
pourquoi mélenchon refusent de venir lui
a pas proposé la business class
peut-être mais non mais non chez moi
c'est un dossier way personal ouais
ouais c'était pas très très bien passé
pour dire le moins on n'est pas couché
c'est bien peu quelque chose qui
revenait c'est dès qu'on conteste
quelque chose vous n'avez pas lu mon
livre ah ouais donc j'avais d'ici et je
les mêmes tellement bien lui que j'ai
relevé toutes les copies et j'avais fait
un relevé de toutes les copies y en
avait une centaine et il avait envoyé je
crois un mot hamon son éditeur que je
connais et qui avait dit la prochaine
fois que je croise n'ose lui pète les
deux jambes et moi j'attends toujours
puisque j'en ai pas vraiment lusage donc
je m'en fous oui mais ne veut pas venir
c'est un signe oui moi je suis aussi
donc j'aimerais que confidence pour
confidence il va mieux et sinon plus
parce que j'ai eu le malheur d'écrire
que c'était les communards qui avaient
incendié le palais des tuileries je
voudrais pas être désagréable on a connu
des révolutionnaires plus courageux oui
moi d'abord et puis ensuite
malheureusement pour jean-luc c'est que
c'est bien les communards quand incendie
l'étude les malouines a voulu
demanderiez quoi mélenchon s'il a des
chaînes ou là par exemple moi je pense
qu'il est l'allié objectif de mâcon donc
mais oui oui c'est plutôt et marie-mai
évidemment imposera une seule question
moi je vous dirais 30 ans apparatchiks
et un matin vous vous réveillez vous
êtes che guevara la question c'est sans
déconner c'est tous
ces cons qui viennent comme
ça fait quand même s'est emparé première
dix ans on ajoute évidemment on n'est
pas couché vous faites comment pour vous
surprendre encore après dix ans de vie
commune eric vous dit des fois des trucs
positifs sur sur les femmes sur les
étrangers pour essayer de possible de
surprendre un peu non comment vous
faites mais je cherche pas du tout elle
surprend non moi je pense qu'il ya deux
catégories de gens il ya les gens qui
pour changer se contredisent il ya les
gens qui ne veulent pas se contredire au
risque de la cohérence moi j'ai choisi
la deuxième catégorie ça peut être
ennuyeux parfois mais bon si la voix ou
eric zemmour se trompe il y a deux
sortes de gens sur terre
ceux qui pensent qu'il y a deux sortes
de gens sur terre et les hommes
non je crois que ce prêt de notre
longévité c'est que c'est une relation
qui n'est pas basée sur le sexe oui
c'est un mariage de raison et ça ça
permet de durer plus longtemps
et plus 1 c'est vrai que ce cas c'est
différent en fait il y en a un qui est
plutôt de droite inquiète plutôt de
gauche inquiets qui ébranle autre qui
est châtain il y en a un que les
méchants et l'autre qui est méchant
vous voyez encore de l'antenne assez peu
ce qui permet de garder une certaine
certaines fiches non mais c'est vrai
alors vous savez que le jour où l'un
d'entre vous va mourir c'est à l'autre
qu'on va demander une réaction me savais
ça est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé ce
que vous allez dire non annoncée mais
heureusement c'est vrai qu'on est pas
inquiété lors du pur imaginez le truc
comme ça mais
c'est intéressant moi oui je dis
qu'est-ce que naulleau pourrait dire bah
si c'est vrai malgré tout c'était mon
ami ou
non et vous pensez quoi de nos loana il
a parfois un don de la répartie que je
vis en vie ouais elles se sentent pas en
revanche je pense que politiquement bois
il comprend pas tout ouais
sinon n'auraient pas d'édition
alors justement eric naulleau suite à
une interview d'eric zemmour dans le
magazine causeur où il expliquait qu'il
respectait les gens prêts à mourir pour
ce en quoi il croit
vous avez affirmé je suis en désaccord
avec chaque syllabe de cette interview
mais je ne pense pas que les zemmouris
ce ne soit contagieux jamais je ne
regretterai d'avoir fait équipe avec
zemmour et jamais je ne trahis les amis
ça s'est assez bien à des sommations à
renier des amitiés nouées c'est très
étrange mais ce que nous mettons que
j'obtempère ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire quoi quelqu'un qui renie un ami
pour obtempérer à quelqu'un d'autre ce
qu'est ce qui se passe dans sa tête
alors laurent ruquier lui regrette
d'avoir fait équipe avec zemmour et de
vous avoir laissé parler aussi longtemps
alors l'âge allait bien on regarde sauf
que la production de on n'est pas couché
ne veux pas me vendre l'extrait où
laurent qui ai dit qu'il faisait trop
laissé parler c'est vrai vous pensez ça
dérisoire ouais here is war il était
bien content que je parle quand je crois
que ça faisait de l'audience et les dix
ans avec ça et ça a animé l'émission et
je ne partage pas toutes vos idées mais
je suis prêt à mourir pour vous puissiez
mais c'est surtout qu' axa condorcet où
on dit que c'est voltaire mais c'est pas
ce mois-là vient épisode et je trouve ce
hangar gamelle c'est moins bien pour
continuer je trouve vraiment quelle
somme à garoua incroyable même moule
incroyable mattei lui a demandé un
autographe
est-ce que vous avez regardé christine
angot dont on n'est pas couché non parce
que moi j'ai déjà lu christine angot ça
me suffit mais vous avez déclaré angot
refusé d'affronter la vie critique des
chroniqueurs d'on n'est pas couché elle
entend désormais donner le sien sur les
livres des autres
oui c'est quand même étrange je sais que
c'est assez répandues comme attitude
mais c'est toujours étrange et par
ailleurs je pense que c'est peut-être la
plus grande imposture littéraire de ces
cinquante dernières années en france
donc pas m'infliger son nom alors
laurent qui a répondu le lot a été un
très bon chroniqueur mais que je sache
il n'a pas pour l'instant vendu beaucoup
de livres parlent dans ta gueule
battle au début du 20e siècle la grande
star vraiment le faisais pas encore best
seller mais celui qui vend des 2
millions livres s'appelait georges aunès
vous avez beaucoup de gens honnêtes
c'est comme si qu'a eu le goncourt en 32
en revanche j'avais un petit gars qui
s'appelait marcel proust ça se vendait
pas beaucoup et puis ça c'est bon tu
combats pas tant que ça par rapport à
jean genet sahraouis non mais laurent
long et qui est persuadé en fait que
vous vous êtes a remis de votre départ
d'on n'est pas couché non mais écoutez
franchement une bonne fois pour toutes
on n'est pas couché je n'ai que des
choses positives à dire ce n'est pas
couché on s'est marré pendant cinq ans
j'ai eu la chance de faire équipe avec
des mots ce mariage aurait fait équipe
avec embauches ne serait pendu dans la
loi non vraiment je ne cracherai jamais
dans la soupe j'ai adoré faire cette
émission s'est ouvert entendre
maintenant quatre musiques à vous allez
me dire laquelle vous correspond le
mieux d'accord
je ne peux pas
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
alors moi c'est un mais calme en route
c'était d'ailleurs là la senelec de la
tradition au début ici la voix une
précision pour tous ceux qui sont
choqués par les gestes sexiste de
laurent baffie sachez qu'il ne le fait
pas par goût ni par conviction il le
fait parce qu'il est grassement payés
bravo la voie non non non en fait ce
qu'il aime comme une fiction télévisée
ça
[Musique]
jamais
nos lois genre hélène ségara cette
chanson cette chambre sur 20 mais je
vais aller me voulait mais même agent la
preuve ouais ouais ouais ouais j'aime
bien tenu et aux bronzés de la paille
alors j'ai reçu beaucoup de noms pas de
tweet parce que je suis pas sur twitter
grâce à dieu j'ai reçu beaucoup de
textos me demandant qu'est ce que cette
chanson pouvait bien être
c'est james white and black comme
tension celle remixé par august darnell
le boss de kid créole alors elle ne
serais pas étonné que je vous fasse une
interview attention piège
[Musique]
alors je vais vous dire dès début de
phrase à venir la fin attention je
cherche à vous piéger zemmour avant
d'accord les femmes sont toutes
culotté magnifique
les musulmans sont tous
des croyants
[Rires]
l'islam est une religion qui
qui a plus de mille ans d'existence
jusque là vous êtes lé bon tous les
juifs sont
pourquoi t'es fait un message hitler
tous les juifs sont peu nombreux
les derniers 1 caen sont tous
basané les délinquants sont tous
dangereux
les chinois à paris son
début la roumaine a
dans certains quartiers
ce
qui me dégoûte en france c'est
la haine de soi
si la france va mal c'est évidemment la
faute de
ces dures d'éviter les pièges wes
surtout que ils sont gros comme de trois
maisons donc
trois maisons closes
qu'il déplaît chez emmanuel macron c'est
qu'il a été élu
ce qu'il faut faire avec les micros
c'est
les renvoyer dans leur pays vous êtes
tombés dans le piège non non et
volontaire ceci pour là je suis pour la
méthode australienne avoir japonaise
madame
en france il ya trop de
cons qui
va nous quitter aussi
honnête sur le compte de quelques rocks
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu